[Music]
this is the story of a miraculous white
powder that is helping to win the war
it's name is
dichlorodiphenyltrichloroethane for
short
DBT it may one day prove our greatest
weapon towards victory over an enemy
more murderous even than the fascist
against disease
time was when disease conditions in
other lands didn't concern us much the
Black Death bubonic plague of India the
Orient Africa periodically sweeping
through the crowded millions transmitted
from the rat to the human by the flea
typhus common to nearly every densely
populated city on earth
explosive epidemics wiping out almost
entire populations transported by the
louse
malaria scourge of the tropics carried
by the Anopheles mosquito and the many
filth diseases that can be borne by
flies including the red cholera but
these were all in far-off places with
strange names and may be in the security
of our homes and families we shuddered
at the thought that such things could
happen in the 20th century and then
suddenly they weren't in another world
after all our own men were out there all
over the globe and disease was as much a
menace as the enemy's bullets we learned
the full import of that at Bataan of our
36,000 troops left in the last days of
Bataan 20,000 were out on their feet or
down with malaria the mosquito had
helped a [ __ ] to bring on the end the
flea allows the fly could bring similar
disaster wherever our men went in
anticipation of this the nation's
scientific resources had already been
marshaled by the War Department to meet
the challenge something new must be
found to fight the Menace of the disease
bearing insect to take the place of
insecticides no longer available because
of the war through the National Research
Council this United States Department of
Agriculture laboratory at
and Oh Florida was one of the several
places in which the work was centered it
was the job of this laboratory to raise
the healthiest sturdiest specimens of
the common disease bearing insects and
then to find the means of killing them
hundreds of insecticides were tried out
here developed from materials sent in
from all parts of the world some were
fairly effective even good compounds and
solutions that dropped a mosquito in
midair could stun a louse
quickly dispatched a fly or a flea but
something better was needed something
that would kill all four insects and
could be produced in the enormous
quantities needed if possible something
that might continue to kill for a few
hours anyway or better a few days after
application November 16th
1942 was the day that brought in a new
insecticide sample from Switzerland an
accompanying letter gave some of the
details
one feature sounded particularly
interesting if a little unbelievable
that was the claim that after a single
application in a barn
this insecticide had continued to kill
flies for a month thereafter but
scientists were accustomed to hearing
exaggerated claims the new material was
given a code number and started along
the testing routine first an elementary
test against lice a solution of the
material is placed in a beaker and the
lice are at it yes it kills but of
course you can't catch all the lice in
the world and put them in beakers now to
apply it in powder form on the body of a
volunteer the lice are placed in a
sleeve on the subjects armed
another sleeve which contains the
standard army delousing powder for
purposes of comparison is removed first
the results are as good as expected with
only a few light surviving now for the
other sleeve dusted with the powder
prepared from the new material
[Music]
results every last louse dead a fuller
test more volunteers harboring lice wear
suits of underwear dusted with the new
material results again every louse dead
the new material then is already an
important discovery a better love
spotter than any now in use but how good
is it against the other vicious three
the mosquito the flea the fly first is
it adaptable readily solvent for use in
solution form yes kerosene diesel oil
even fueled and crankcase oil dissolve
it easily that's promising
it's easy to get these materials in the
field an emulsion is readily prepared
with both fresh and saltwater it is
shown really remarkable qualities for
dispersion and suspension in every
medium tested very valuable if it's
killing properties in these agents prove
out its action against the common pest
mosquito is excellent dissolved in fuel
oil a tenth of a pound per acre is
enough to kill every mosquito in the
area but it's the Anopheles mosquito
that carries malaria what about that a
little stronger dosage is needed but
it's still amazingly potent this is a
find in dust form it has many advantages
over the old standby Paris green against
the malaria carrying monopolies
the laboratory scientists now know the
material is good very good that's
definite and now what if that
information that came in the letter with
it about still killing weeks after the
first application in a testing chamber
just a box with a glass cover a light
spray of the material in five percent
emulsion was applied then the scientists
waited 48 hours at the end of that time
flies were put in the box big healthy
flies in five minutes they were in
violent convulsions in a little while
they'll all be dead
check mosquitos next the malaria kind
they didn't last as long as the Flies
and another day had gone by the spray
was a day older cockroaches the next day
sure death and six days after the
original spraying lice were put in the
lethal effects of the insecticide hadn't
weakened an appreciable amount and this
was not the end of its fantastic
strength 14 months later one year in two
months after that original spray without
a drop being added the new insecticide
was still killing all comers almost as
quickly as on the first day
another thing clothing impregnated with
an emulsion of the substance was still
killing lice after the clothing had been
thoroughly laundered from six to eight
times science had come on it's greatest
weapon against the insect killer an
incredible new weapon against disease
the War Department was quick to put the
new substance into use in the field
under the abbreviated name DDT what let
a medical officer tell you how effective
it is proved DDT is the most powerful of
the new weapons which the army is now
using in this war on the insect borne
diseases the development of this weapon
affords a spectacular example of the
effective way in which all of the
scientific agencies of this country have
cooperated with the medical departments
of the Armed Forces because we are armed
with DDT we no longer fear typhus fever
this chemical affords protection to
American soldiers against the mosquitos
that carry malaria yellow fever dengue
filariasis and against the ever-present
flies that spread certain filth diseases
DDT is now being used by the army and
all of our tropical fears however there
is still much to be learned about it and
therefore our research collaborators
continue their investigations in the
laboratory and in the field we already
know of the miraculous results it is
produced but its full potential it is
against all the insects that spread
disease must be determined I consider
this amazing chemical the most valuable
contribution of our wartime medical
research program the future health and
welfare not only of this nation but of
the entire world
this part of the world has already
experienced the effectiveness of DDT in
one of the miracles of modern medical
history
this was Naples Italy shortly after the
Allied occupation it's crowded
population lacked almost everything for
the safeguarding of public health food
fuel blankets housing clothing
sanitation and refugees from all parts
of Italy were swarming in with them the
louse the perfect setup for epidemic and
then it struck typhus the Naples area
was immediately placed off-limits to
Allied military personnel within armies
typhus has
and lost more Wars than all of the
strategy and weapons ever developed
[Music]
but for the jams civilian population of
Naples there seemed little hope
winter was only arriving when typhus hit
Naples and never in history had a typhus
epidemic ended before the warmth of
spring then DDT was brought in dusting
with DDT was begun at once first every
case of typhus was tracked down and
every person who had been exposed was
rid of the murderous louse by the powder
next the 40,000 Italians welling in the
jam-packed air-raid shelters were
deloused
[Music]
finally 43 DDT stations were set up
throughout the city and the entire
remaining population was dusted in
January when the large scale dusting
started 60 new cases of typhus a day
were being reported another month and it
might well have been 600 or 6,000 cases
a day yet by the middle of February the
menace of the epidemic was over DDT had
won by not only removing the lights when
dusted but by continuing to kill long
after application preventing
reinfestation in the Pacific
DDT goes to war against malaria in a big
way by airplane on d-day at Morotai we
get both enemies at the same time the
[ __ ] and disease simultaneous with the
bombing of our two-legged enemy we went
after the mosquito with DDT spray and as
a result of the spray malaria was
already under control before our troops
set foot on the island
the Japanese did not live long enough to
enjoy the island rid of mosquitoes by
DDT yes
today DDT is necessarily a military
weapon we're turning it out by the
thousands of tons but every ounce is
needed for the war effort
when the fascist is finally beaten
though DDT will be available to all
already it has been found to be highly
effective against many kinds of
agricultural insect pests
it will Hayden stamping out disease
around the world
[Music]
and the homecoming of the healthiest
army in military history
will be in no small part due to DDT our
great new weapon for war today and peace
tomorrow
[Music]